[Music]
good morning John it's uh
is possible that I have a hangover good
morning John it's Friday August 3rd
something I want to talk about today
aside from your punishment three times
in the last week something interesting
is happen to meet a retail store first
time I was getting sand I was like this
bag looks good and he was like oh that
one has a rip in it you can just take it
and I was like yeah thing that I was
gonna buy now I just get to take and I
did and I took it and I took it home and
then the other day I went to the book
exchange which is this book store where
you take books and then they give you
credit and then you get books again and
so it's kind of like a library except
you get to keep the books if you want to
and I went in there and I got some books
and I already had a bunch of credit
though I gave him the books and he boop
boop boop and then he handed me the
books and I had my wallet out and he was
like you want to use you credit for this
right and I was like yes yes I would
like to use my credit my wallet back in
my pocket and I was like oh no when I
took my wallet out and then the other
day I was heading home from the garden I
was really hungry on the way home from
the garden is a convenience store which
sells the cheapest corn dogs in town ah
two for a dollar and so I went in there
and I only had 70 cents so I had enough
for one corn dog it was drink let me
change my hand and I looked in there
were no corn dogs 70 cents is enough to
buy a corn dog but 70 cents is not
enough to buy anything else I said I
don't think I have enough money to buy
anything you got she looked a little bit
sort of sad for me and then I said you
don't have any corn dogs back there that
you're hiding she said no and then she
said do you just want something and I
was like yes I want that cheeseburger
and she gave me the cheeseburger I can
haz Cheezburger kind of looked around to
see if her boss was looking and then she
was like pink cheeseburger and I took it
and I ate it and it wasn't very good but
it was you know dinner but all three of
those times it actually felt really
weird and felt like I was breaking a
rule the retail store dance that you do
ding ding dings have passed
taketake pass taketake shunk
ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding
push-button
push-button ding Kuching corrosion
dddd dddd path pass thank you thank you
bye have a good day
you too know that happened this is very
elaborate sort of ritual surrounding the
exchange of goods and it was just all
gone and then but you saved that person
thank you what you say when you get a
cheeseburger from someone who uses pay
what do you say to a person who you get
a cheeseburger from who didn't pay you
have to say something like super nice
like thank you I will never forget you
until I die
you want like say that to the gas
station lady how was she gonna respond
to that oh oh I shouldn't have given
that guy a free cheeseburger now he
wants to do me uh yeah anyway
Nair fighters discovered the jutsu
actually communicated with me ten days
after this project started and you must
be punished nerdfighters and I got an
excellent suggestion from a guy named
Dave who says that you should have to
call and spend at least one minute
talking to an ex-girlfriend during this
call you will have to mention certain
things and what those things are I would
like to ask the nerdfighters to suggest
but well done getting your video up last
night I was very impressed and very sort
of suppressed see it because I heard
that you might not be making it so
awesome good job as a final note you may
have noticed that the world type meter
has been elevated to SEC level orange
this is because of the disaster in
Minneapolis you being caught in a
punishable offense and secret sister
Katie getting kicked out of her house I
so recently dodged that bullet that I'm
feeling kind of bad for Katie good luck
fight through it
John I'll see you on Monday I will
tweeze one nipple hair for $25